hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast he an AI beat cancer
presented by Marty Tenenbaum founder and
chairman at cancer Commons I'm Alexis
Krause of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
lackwits is the leading scientific
social networking website and produce
their up virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the brush and the board at
the bottom center of your screen or use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me and welcoming dr.
Tannenbaum I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello today I'm
going to talk about AI and cancer from
my unique perspective as a computer
scientist a internet entrepreneur and a
cancer survivor
I'm going to talk about 40 years of AI
research on cancer which has resulted in
thousands of papers published and lots
of demonstrations but very little
clinical impact and then talk about what
I've been trying to do to fix that
in cancer Commons and organization when
I started to help patients get the best
possible outcomes and continuously learn
from every patient and in the end to
talk about how you can contribute to
this mission in order to be able to make
a real difference in terms of saving
lives I think the potential exists to
save
of thousands of lives a year starting
immediately with the tools at our
disposal and the drugs that are disposal
almost twenty years ago I was diagnosed
with wicked answer Sadek melanoma to
liver and given like nine to twelve
months to live this was in the era
before there are all these miracle check
inhibitors and so forth and I went
around to lots of different doctors
everyone told me something different and
the only thing these Doc's could agree
on was that the prognosis was dire so
what to do and this is a situation that
hasn't changed much in twenty years in
fact it's gotten more complicated
because there are you know many more
good options to choose but in the end I
bet my life I'm a clinical trial and
that clinical trial felt but I was
fortunate to be on a long tail of
exceptional responders and so I
dedicated the rest of my career at that
point to take my skills as a computer
scientist an internet entrepreneur and
use them to try to help other patients
going through this kind of decision
where you actually have to sometimes
make a decision often make a decision in
real time you know within days a
life-or-death decision with not the
information that you need to make the
best possible decision twenty years
later the situation as I said is really
pretty much the way it was then people
get diagnosed they go into a panic they
go consult Google and it says something
like 1.7 million results came back and I
can guarantee you that the first 20
pages or 50 pages of Google results are
not going to be what you need because
ovale is good at many things but finding
a needle in the haystack that one study
that is gives you the possibility to
save your life it's not going to be
there this is the paper that saved my
life and in fact the doc who saved my
life and I never would have found it if
I was just googling for metastatic
melanoma to liver because this paper
wasn't published in science or the New
York Times it was published and
some annals of surgery and it would have
been very hard to find so this is part
of the disconnect between extraordinary
amount of information that gets
published every year and the information
that a patient or a doctor for that
matter needs in order to make an
informed decision this is I just got
back from ASCO you know a couple of days
ago it was last week and this is the
annual meeting there's 10,000 people in
this room so if you can picture it going
back as for as far as it can and they're
all listening to some sages on the stage
talking about you know a few cancer
trials and this is you know anything
discussed on that stage is going to be
you know three maybe even five years
behind what you'll hear in hallway
conversations and then once it's
published it'll take another 17 years or
thereabouts to diffuse through you know
continuing medical education for example
and conferences and ultimately a
patient's showing up with something that
they just took gone off the web asking
doc what do you think about you know
this treatment of this trial to it for
it to diffuse out into you know the
front lines of oncology say in West
Virginia or some other rural place and
this is you know this stuff is needs to
change and AI is the way it has to
change in the only way it's going to
change and this stuff has consequences
no medical knowledge treatments and
results fall off very sharply as you
move away from the elite cancer centers
and out into the community and beyond
community practice in urban areas out
into the rural communities the
disadvantaged communities the
third-world communities and being screen
on that picture on the on the right
shows how it varies across Europe for
the same cancer for patients diagnosed
if we can just get everyone up to the
level the best we will already have
saved you know hundreds of thousands of
lives a year and if we can then raise
the level of the best for everyone which
countless more the challenge is that no
one knows the app will feed any two with
the books that are available and I let
you need to let this thing sink you for
a second
the reason is because these drugs are
seldom tested in regimens cocktails or
head-to-head with each other even and as
a result there are so many plausible
ways you can imagine using the mm cancer
drugs that we already have but no one
has no one knows how to figure out an
efficient way to search that space and
search is one of the things that AI was
born to do to show you something about
the illustrate the tremendous
combinatorics that we're talking about
here what you're seeing is cancer as it
was maybe 40 years ago at the beginning
of the war on cancer so cancer was a
ten-by-ten disease along the bottom or
you know lung breast colon all the major
organs that's why cancer was
characterized and up on the vertical
axis are the ten or so chemo therapies
that kept getting recycled over and over
again across all these different cancers
so you had a ten by ten experimental
metric matrix there are about a million
cancer patients a year who are you know
eligible for clinical trials and so you
have ten thousand patients a box you
know a million patients a hundred boxes
ten thousand patients you can run plenty
of clinical trials today the situation
is quite a bit different
there are thousands perhaps millions of
molecular subtypes of cancer no one
really knows that for sure and the
vertical axis now has you know thousands
maybe tens of thousands of plausible
combinations and regiments of drugs that
might be useful for treating cancer so
we have somewhere between a hundred
million and a billion boxes no one
really knows for sure but still
fortunately only a million patients so
if you do the math there's approximately
zero or in computer science we would say
epsilon patients per box and you can't
really run
miles anymore and you can't and Big Data
doesn't work for the same reason there's
not any big data in those boxes and to
put it even more sharply let me ask a
rhetorical question which is how much
data is there on something that hasn't
been tried yet and if you think about
that for a second you'll recognize the
limitations of all of the Big Data
approaches that people are doing to try
to understand cancer not the data isn't
important but that there simply isn't
any data on things that haven't been
tried yet so what I'm going to be
talking about is using AI not to analyze
big data but to figure out what data we
need and then to be able to plan an
optimal series of experiments sequential
hypothesis testing in order to be able
to get the data that we need as quickly
and efficiently as possible and we can
base these experiments on all sorts of
knowledge including preclinical data
causal models if someone has them that
they can run experimental pre clinical
results high-throughput drug screens for
example or most importantly what the
experts at the top places are thinking
about in terms of the experiments they
want to run so in and we'll get to that
in just one second but first I want to
comment that cancer is a very very hard
a AI problem and you've all heard about
you know in the headlines of all the
things that cancer and but big data is
being used for nowadays including
winning games like go and chess and so
forth where but the best you know
experts in the world are computers now
and so if they in a game like go the
situation is that the rules are fixed
there's they've been fixed for thousands
of years being there's plenty of data
there's perfect simulations if you need
to play experiments which is you know
playing games
that's pretty cost effective to do in
fact you can play it against yourself
all night long and learn
so the fact that can that pay I can win
go there's a lot of things going for it
that make it easy
similarly driving which is self-driving
cars is another major win for AI recent
years and we're getting pretty close to
commercial offerings Google drives cars
around my neighborhood here in Silicon
Valley all the time but they're the
rules of the road have been fixed for
like almost 100 and we have again plenty
of data and perfect simulations we can
simulate things and getting people with
drive cars around is not that expensive
but if we get to cancer the situation is
quite a bit different first of all there
are no rules cancer makes its own rules
and it's changing them all the time
there's very little data in terms of
treatments and outcomes that people are
willing to share in any case and as ice'
pointed out very little data on the
interesting things that haven't been
tried yet we don't have good simulators
the best simulators that we have are
mice they're neither sheep nor fast they
give you results like in months of
you're lucky and whether those results
are even applicable to people is hard to
say and the experiments are very very
costly in terms of both dollars and
human lives and so we have to you know
look at man-machine approaches so now
getting back to what do you do when you
don't have you know good data or good
studies in which to base your
experiments and that is you turn to the
best minds that you have and find out
what they are thinking and try to tap
that and today you see experiments
happening all the time in oncology they
happen in community oncology offices
where Doc's are talking to patients and
figuring out something some experiment
to do and no one is in the room with
them capturing that if you're luckily
you know some of the thinking will get
into the patient's record but that of
course is protected by HIPAA rules and
most importantly in major cancer centers
we now have these molecular tumor boards
so they're springing up
everywhere and here not just physicians
but also often scientists and
computational scientists covering the
bioinformatics or discussing the
toughest cases and virtually nothing is
captured and so this is a problem and so
the first thing that we need to do is to
get into these rooms and try to capture
the information that's happening every
day these experiments are going on
people are thinking about and trying
things and no one is capturing these
this information all of oncology in fact
is an experiment if we're honest about
it and these experiments are not planned
they're not coordinated they're not
observed in any central way and
therefore very little is learned from
them so this is the opportunity that
we're a I can make a huge difference ok
let's go back to the ASCO meeting if I
had a recurrence of my cancer and I went
up to the front of this room I would
want to not have people tell me about
the results of trials which have taken
five to ten years and then another year
to report out in an ESCO meeting I would
like to say these are the details of my
case
does anyone have any ideas about what I
should do and by the way not just in
this room but in the whole world so the
questions there there are the basically
three three cases that can happen here
number one is somewhere in the world an
expert knows what's best for me it's
just not my doctor and how do we make
that connection from where the knowledge
is to where it needs to get to number
two is no individual knows but
collectively the community knows someone
may know you know what targets to hit
given the molecular profile of my cancer
and someone else may know what drugs are
appropriate to use for that target or
may be a clinical trial that they're
running that my doc doesn't know about
so if we can connect the dots then we
have an opportunity to do that number
three is
to where there's no one in the community
who knows the answer but collectively we
know what's the next best thing to do
maybe if we had some view of looking at
the entire of the entire community and
could see that some people are thinking
about something and over here some
people are thinking about something
similar maybe we could put those pieces
together and know what experiment to run
so if I look at these things organizing
the world's knowledge connecting the
dots which is inference and learning
coordinating the search for new
knowledge these are not you know cancer
or bio research problems these are very
hard a eye problems and they have the
potential to save many many lives a year
if we can in fact solve them and I would
go so far as to say they're the only
thing that can make an immediate
difference of that scale being able to
exploit better the resources the drugs
and the tests that we already have okay
so that's the context now let's move to
look at what a eye has done so far
because these are the building blocks
that we will be using in new ways when
we get to the third quarter of the talk
so my colleague Jeff Schrager and I
about 20 years ago excuse me 10 years
ago now wrote a paper for the AI
magazine which is the magazine published
by the AI Triple A I which is the AI
professional society in which we laid
out the opportunities for AI and cancer
and for anyone who wants a comprehensive
review the challenges that we laid out
and the approaches to them are still as
applicable today as they were then so
take a look at this paper in AI magazine
I think it was in the summer of twenty
and 2011 and the paper concluded by
talking about the grand challenges the
grand challenge that we posed to the
community at that point which was
organize the world's knowledge of cancer
use that
be able to plan and coordinate the
treatment experiments that are being
done everyday in oncology integrate the
results so that we can increase our
knowledge of both cancer biology and and
the drug mechanisms and then generalize
that knowledge so we can apply it to
many many more patients and this
challenge turn may be a lot harder than
I thought I thought in these current
last 10 years that we would have gotten
there but in fact we're still far from
achieving these goals so let me go back
to something more fundamental which is
to try and give you some sense of what a
I can and cannot do today and in the
near future so speaking generally what I
eye does is take data in the various
forms that it's shown here and knowledge
as we might get from experts or
literature or there are other sources
and be able to use that knowledge to
build models and these models can be
represented in various forms they can be
statistical models or rule-based
knowledge or plans or what have you
build models and then use those models
in conjunction with real data from an
actual patient in order to be able to do
things like diagnosis and treatment
planning and being able to you know
monitor response recommend people the
trials all those sorts of things which
AI does the very first AI oh and I
should say that in addition to clinical
applications there are pre clinical
applications many of them and AI is
being used throughout the industry
increasingly to do things like Target
discovery and molecule design and
molecule optimization and treatment
validation and so forth I'm not going to
be talking about those preclinical
applications directly today except as
they may be relevant in certain clinical
applications for example in terms of
being able to find targets in a given
patient and drugs that might be
recommended for them maybe we can
repurpose some of those
and if any of you out there are working
on such applications I would really like
to hear from you if we can find a way to
repurpose them clinically the very
earliest expert systems I excuse me the
very earliest AI applications were
expert systems which the very first of
which was uncle Sen which was done in 10
short lifts lab here at Stanford and the
these systems used handcrafted rules in
which the experts would put down what
conditions they were looking for and
based on those what they would recommend
and used for being able to make
treatment plans for oncology patients
and the these systems are you know now
30 or 40 years old and they're still in
use today and they're still very very
good in terms of capturing what experts
are thinking in a narrow domain of
discourse and being able to apply them
to a given problem they're used all the
time in diagnosis for example of
equipment in machinery and they're used
throughout medicine that said they are
not very good at handling uncertainty
and learning means is all done manually
namely you learn something the rules
change you have to go back and you have
to edit the rules and these rules
typically interact with each other so
the editing becomes a huge mess and
that's what I mean by knowledge
management and as a result expert
systems are limited the current paradigm
that we're talking about is using big
data in order to be able to train the
models and these largely statistical
models and big data is very good at
things where for which there's a lot of
data for example radiology stands or
pathology slides or even being able to
do medical diagnosis and treatment
planning in narrow contexts where the
where you have a lot of data which is
not cancer where the interesting things
haven't been done yet and so the
challenge with these systems are they
don't
work very well in situations where you
don't have a lot of data and they don't
work you don't provide explanations you
know the neural net says that this is
best so that's the answer and that's
basically a non-starter if you're really
trying to use these things seriously in
a clinical setting
third wave which is one that is just you
know emerging now and you'll be hearing
more about it is using statistical
techniques to be able to invoke models
which are in the form of programs and
these programs can be run and make
predictions and compared with the with
the environment and based on that we can
you know do learning in much the same
way that a child does using small
numbers of examples and being able to
you know reason about why my program
isn't working correctly and debugging
the program and there's a lot of
theories that this that explain the
children how children might be learning
in this kind of way so if you have small
amounts of data you want to be able to
explain how things work probabilistic
programming is a paradigm that you
should be looking into so as I said at
the beginning of this talk there have
been you know 40 years of researched
thousands of academic papers but very
little clinical impact and the reasons
are actually straightforward and not all
that much directly related to the
abilities or lack thereof of AI but
rather all of the contextual things that
need to get done integration into
physician workflows and there you know
EHR systems knowledge management as we
talked about earlier with the expert
systems clinical validation which is
actually seeing how well the results you
know compared to you know traditional
Doc's doing their things which can take
quite a while to do and therefore
haven't been done very much and that's
one reason that we don't see widespread
clinical adoption and then simply all of
the issues that are involved in product
ization and marketing of these systems
so that
they are not you know research demos but
there's something that could be used in
a physician's office by someone with
minimal training and we're beginning to
see some progress on that last front in
particular if we look at where oncology
is going we're very close to the time
when we are going to be seeing in
routinely in cancer because of a focus
on precision oncology people patients
getting really quite comprehensive panel
molecular panels which are talking which
we'll cover you know DNA RNA proteomics
and so forth and then being able to take
the results of that and put that into
models of molecular pathways I am in
fact even more sophisticated models that
will model what's going on in a Cell in
a mathematical way so that we can try to
predict what's going on the cells of
that patient and then doing
sophisticated treatment planning which
can involve you know tests a sequential
trying to map out not just what the
patient does next but sequentially what
options are open they're closed based on
each thing that they do so there's a
kind of planning and look ahead which is
again something AI is very good at being
able to run tests preclinical tests
either in the dish or in an animal or in
a computer as to whether you know how
well that's working being able to apply
the combos and then be able to monitor
in real-time and I would say that in
support of this new paradigm precision
oncology there's an emerging ecosystem
with many hundreds of companies that are
developing systems and software for
being able to deliver the services that
I've talked about and every one of these
companies you can bet has a team that is
doing something that involves AI and
often this is marketed with a lot of
buzz but there's a lot of stealth behind
it I don't really know what's happening
neither does anyone else
yet and so
these are what we have to look forward
to coming on stream in the next few
years but and here's the caveat just
like no one knows the optimal way to use
the drugs we already have in combination
no one knows the optimal way to use all
these tests agreements and at the end of
the day we need to find a way to
optimize not just the drugs but the
tests and treatments to create create
regimens or treatment pathways if you
like that are optimal for each patient
and that's the challenge that we will
need to be facing so I'm gonna add two
more things to the issues that I talked
about a second ago which is how do we
integrate all of these emergent AI
capabilities that that not I'm
developing but that all of you are
developing in your companies into
regiments and then how do we create a
rational marketplace whereby all of
these capabilities are out there in a
way that people can discover you know
when I was walking the trade show at
ASCO last weekend there was no way
anyone could keep that stuff in their
head it's just a completely
dysfunctional marketplace so we need to
create the marketplace first and then
try to standardize all these things so
that they plug in place of the output if
someone's molecular profiling is going
as is then the input to the next
person's tumor modeling target
identification and that is the input
that someone's treatment planner and so
on and so forth that's what's needed in
order to be able to turn these
capabilities into something that is a
scalable approach to using AI to solve
cancer which brings me to what we're
doing at Cancer Commons Cancer Commons
is something I started about 10 years
ago with the explicit goal of helping
patients and their physicians find the
optimal treatments for them and to learn
as much as possible from each patient's
experience to inform the next patient so
you can imagine that if we do deep
research on behalf of one or two
patients that that research might
benefit
or perhaps a thousand additional
patients that have similar cancers we
disseminate the information to the front
lines as rapidly as we can not in 17
years
but in real time in response to queries
about what do I do to help a particular
patient and then we try to coordinate
all of these treatments in order to
maximize learning more on that in a
second cancer Commons premier service up
till this point has been a free service
that we offer supported by philanthropy
which provides one-on-one consulting
second opinions if you like to cancer
patients who have exhausted the standard
of care so these are patients who are
out of options and are looking for new
treatment guidelines and we fix them up
with our internal experts and and
provide them recommendations often
recommendations about clinical trials
which in a very deep way are matched to
their particular molecular profiles and
whatever other criteria they bring in
terms of patient preferences in order to
be able and we've helped so far a few
thousand patients interestingly in 40
countries and I know this webinar is
global so if you have patients and you
would like to consult ask Cancer Commons
the service is free
and it's very highly regarded by the
patients who have benefitted from it and
their physicians but scaling this is a
challenge and I've already talked about
one way of scaling it which is reusing
results another way is to build out a
network of external physicians and we
are in the process of doing that we have
about a hundred physicians that we can
refer cases to now and moderate
discussions among them in order to be
able to facilitate if there's you know
people are not agreeing to try to bribe
consensus which is unfortunately often
the case in oncology because this stuff
is you know really as much art as
science what we're doing beyond that is
building a network that will tap into
tumor boards first in order to be able
to capture these cases and
puling those cases with our own ask
cases to build a knowledge library and
then building partnerships with and with
advocacy groups and industry in order to
be able to to summon that you know be
able to reach far more patients and
disseminate the knowledge much more
widely so we're going to now use the
Cancer Commons network in order to be
able to solve the problem that I was
initially put up there in history mind
you windows they opted to use available
cancer therapies and this I posed as a
very high dimensional search problem in
which probabilistic planning search and
optimization problem which AI is
uniquely poised to solve so what we're
doing is expanding the cancer Commons
Network and into a national and
ultimately a global network that will
turn the oncology into a virtual trial
and I mean that in the very specific
sense which as a way to be able to learn
in the course of real-world evidence to
be able to learn from all patients on
all treatments all the time to be able
to build out this network by starting
with molecular tumor boards and the lead
cancer centers and then expanding that
out so that everyone is part of this
network using it in order to be able to
find out and what is the optimal
treatment for each patient to get help
in adaptively planning the treatment for
that patient based on the experiences of
all the patients that have come before
them in order to be able to come up with
the best treatment for the current
patient and then to be able to
coordinate all of those experiments to
be able to maximize collective learning
that is if you have individual
experiments that are going on and
everyone's for example trying the same
thing you don't get a lot of learning if
we can distribute the experiments across
the community and then be able to very
rapidly replicate the successes and
discard the failures
when there's truly a split decision to
be able to run the experiments this is
where we are using AI to be able to do
this planning and coordination and
knowledge sharing so the first step is
building out the knowledge network and
as I said it is combining our own
network which is in the lower left with
the with lower left let's say the left
with the molecular knowledge tumor
boards on the right and by the way
industry itself can inject hypotheses
into this mix with with appropriate you
know conflicts disclaimed but the goal
is to be able to get all of the
hypotheses that ought to be tried so
that they can be openly discussed and
evaluated for each and every patient
then to be able to use probabilistic
planning
I remember we talked about probabilistic
programming second you know to use
probabilistic planning in order to be
able to coordinate the treatments across
all the patients to maximize learning
you know very simple example again is if
in looking at all of these different
discussions we see that two people want
to try something over here and three
people are talking about something
related over there we can very quickly
organize a case series because none of
the Centers may see enough patients
individually but we can do that and be
able to drive learning in this kind of
pop-up cohort way and the next step
beyond that which we are gearing up to
do but they're not doing yet is to be
able to coordinate all of these
experiments globally to maximize
information gain my colleague Jeff
shraeger
likes to equate this to a air traffic
control system for biomedicine and the
analogy to the air traffic control
system for airplanes is actually pretty
Act namely an air traffic control we
have coordinated teams of
experts and algorithms who are trying to
coordinate all the flight plans of these
planes to be able to get a lot more
planes through a given airspace
efficiently and safely and nothing like
that exists in cancer today but we think
the opportunity is there to be able to
do that so here we are at you know
30,000 feet let's dive down and see what
happens at the point of care and this is
the basically the outline of the way
this works at where the rubber meets the
road is where the patient is being
treated so we have if you like starting
with a patient presenting to a molecular
tumor board and this tumor board based
on the characteristics of the patient is
going to get recommendations from the
Bayesian engine maybe you know three or
four top recommendations which are
produced initially by experts because
there isn't a lot of data although Wyck
there is data later we'll be able to
combine those two and importantly they
will get not just the the
recommendations but the rationale for
those recommendations and they will be
able than to be able to pick the
recommendation that they like and you
know go treat the patients or
interestingly if they don't like and we
will ask them excuse me when they pick
one to tell us which one they picked and
why because that's how we learn and
importantly if they don't like any of
our recommendations they can pick one
that they like better and tell us why
because we'll certainly learn that way
too as well as how it worked when they
tried it and that puts new knowledge
continuously into the system so the way
this now works is if once the tumor
board is made decision captured the
rationale the left-arrow is the
rationale that's being captured into the
knowledge base and the right arrow is go
treat the patient and captioned data on
how it works so over time we're taking
knowledge from the knowledge base on the
left running experiments that are
mediated by the tumor board we're not
trying to practice medicine we're just
giving them suggest
but the suggestions are such as to drive
consensus or coordination in a gentle
way that lets them still be docs and
then capture the data so that over time
we're turning knowledge into data which
of course drives more knowledge and the
loop closes all the stuff on the bottom
of this picture are basically setting up
the Bayesian priors for running this
experiment so the knowledge is being
seeded from the literature and clinical
trial results and the data is being
seeded by various databases that
wouldn't get ones hands on as well as
increasingly on patient undated that the
patient's themselves are contributing so
based on this we are piloting both the
virtual tumor board Network and the
virtual trials in brain cancer and we're
currently seeing about 5-6 patients a
week and we hope to be able to drive
this up to a hundred patients a month by
the end of the year we are also piloting
it in pediatric medulloblastomas
simultaneously and to put a face on this
this this child
Erol mcdowell is really struggling at
the moment in sad to say and his parents
are very successful they were the
founders of airborne which is the cold
remedy that you can pick up in
drugstores and they went on CBS
television with this clean they said we
have all the money in the world can we
get someone to develop you know a cancer
treatment for our son what they are now
doing is sponsoring the running of a
virtual tumor board for their son and
others who have similar grade for
medulla by soma and this is generating
leads and these leads go far beyond the
typical you know handful that a given
oncologist will give you there's now
several dozen of them
are more than anyone patient can do and
so the opportunity now is to be able to
take these leads that were generated
from one patient and be able to
distribute them in this coordinated way
across the community of all kids with
medulloblastomas so that they can
collectively explore the space far more
efficiently than they could as
individuals again in this spirit that if
something's working we sent more
patients there it's not working we send
patients somewhere else and we run the
experiments that need to get run in
order to be able to resolve equipoise so
what this means and you know in terms of
what we're doing is simultaneous cohort
analysis because these cohorts are
dynamic they're changing all the time
treatment planning and experiment
planning surrounded by a platform which
is adding knowledge sharing and
coordination on top of the usual data
sharing that is common in cooperative
groups I'm going to also show you a few
slides on what the air traffic control
you know panels control panels look like
and this is the app that we're using to
coordinate these virtual trials what
you're looking at is a screen that looks
was designed in the spirit of a kayak
travel app so that if you put a patient
in you'll get precisely that one patient
out but you can move the sliders in
order to be able to relax the age or the
months of that you've been surviving
since your diagnosis or biomarkers or
what have you and thereby getting a set
of patients and what this is showing at
the moment is their sliders as wide as
possible and there's it looks like
there's 700 and something patients in
this database and then you can move the
sliders to correspond to a patient which
is receiving the standard of care for a
newly diagnosed patient which is
basically that they have partial
resection or as much as resection as you
could have radiation and Temodar and and
putting that in there's 11 patients who
have been treated that way in this
database and here they are all 11 of
them and if you mouse over these
the horizontal axis is months of
survival and the vertical axis is
independent living score which is
surrogate for quality of life
so what you want are the three dots the
linear dots in the upper right which are
you know people who have lived the
longest amount and the best and if you
mouse over those interestingly you can
begin to see things that are already
informative all those patients shared
one thing in common which is that they
all received intra operative
chemotherapy a wafer was implanted at
the time but they had surgery and that
you know he looted drug locally and that
seems to make a difference to of these
patients were actually on the same drug
and so that bears for the scrutiny but
unfortunately all of these patients you
know are now deceased
this is English EBM is a wicked cancer
of which there are the most 5% long-term
survivors so more is needed and so this
is everything I've shown you so far is
looking retrospectively back at data
let's now look prospectively which is
what the virtual trial is fundamentally
about and what you see here are for the
same cohort basically these are what the
expert recommendations for for those
patients on a slightly different scale
the horizontal scale is not months
anymore but just simply efficacy on a
scale from zero to a hundred relative
efficacy where Timman are the standard
of care is 5050 and similarly the
vertical axis is safety again with
Temodar 5050 being the standard so all
of these dots which are all clinical
trials as it turns out are you judged me
at least as safe as seminar and more
efficacious for this particular patient
if it was me I would go for the the one
the orange dot on the top which might
not be the most efficacious because this
is all forward-looking just crowd crowd
sourced rankings but certainly the
safest it has been a perfect safety
record for that particular drug
so the
is this is where the predictions excuse
me the big planning comes from and then
the goal is to turn that into data so
that this thing runs to the closed loop
one final display is this cancer map
which is another way to look at the data
this is all the patients in the database
matching a certain setting of the
sliders so there's a particular cohort
and these are all the things that
patients in that cohort did from the
starting point which is where they are
at this moment in time some went up some
one down greens is better than brown in
terms of outcomes thicker lines are more
patients and thinner lines so this kind
of flow diagram is a very interesting
way to be able to look at the entire air
traffic control system and see what all
the patients are doing and how well it's
working and this is what we can use to
be able to plan treatments in an
effective way including being able to
say that you know if you have two
treatments that you're contemplating do
them first a then B rather than B than a
if if in fact reversing them kind of
gets you out of the inclusion exclusion
criteria of the of the trials you want
to be and so one order works you get two
shots on goal the other doesn't those
are the kinds of things that we're
trying to do here I might add one less
thing which is that ideally AI can be
used to be able to match patients in two
cohorts show me all patients similar to
the one I have it's a very hard problem
because they're you know multiple
dimensions along which you might want to
match you know sometimes age is
important sometimes it's not and there
are countless other parameters that's
why we're using a kayak like model
because what we're doing is building a
train a database of training data with
people providing the matching this is
the cohort I want and we will use that
in order to be able to Train clustering
algorithms which we're hoping to do
starting next year and and that's the
design philosophy for much of what's
going on in the system this man-machine
system now going back to all of these
companies and they're designing stealth
AI we need to integrate those into this
process and again there's countless
combinatorial ways of being able to
integrate tests with each other
and tests with drugs and no one on the
planet knows how to do it and therefore
it all this needs to be incorporated
into the kind of search process that
we're using and people will be
experimenting with tests all the time
just as they do with drugs we're going
to learn over that space as well but
this is the reason why my colleague Jeff
says that cancer doesn't need a moonshot
it needs an air traffic control system
just to be able to do something but no
one on the planet knows how to do which
brings me to the final part of the call
this is where you all come in because
cancer Commons is building an air
traffic control system but it's not
something that any one organization can
do and certainly we are not in the
position to build all the things that
need to be controlled within this air
traffic control system so the key pieces
as shown here the knowledge sharing
piece the coordination piece at the
level of the pop-up cohorts the virtual
trial the global coordination to
maximize information gain over all those
experiments and then the decision
support where the rubber meets meets the
road Michael Jordan professor at
Berkeley here in the Bay Area has
published a piece recently on medium
that is actually quite provocative
talking about the fact that for people
who are building planetary scale
knowledge systems and this is the type
of thing I talk about in Medan but you
can have be you can imagine any systems
in transportation or science or
what-have-you
all of the issues that they're talking
about on this slide being able to deal
with what are they you know main things
that need to be integrated whether the
api's for those what are the rules of
the road what are the standards for
being able to integrate these things
into workflows and be able to build on
those workflows etc this is a this is a
discipline in and of itself but doesn't
exist today needs to happen so for those
of you who are you know into
building informatics platforms we can
certainly use your help and trying to
make this part of the platform more
robust and we are creating an industry
alliance which is bringing together
everyone that is on you know ideally
everyone on the floor at ASCO is
something to contribute in helping
patients so that we can work together to
figure out how to make all this work
within the context of a global air
traffic control system so that leaves me
for a call to action and this is
something that I'm you know going to ask
each of you to think very hard about
what you have that you might be able to
bring to the table that can be helpful
to patients and helpful to your company
to see integrated with other services in
a way such that we can optimize patient
treatment so the first of all if you are
you know running tumor boards or in
associated with an institution that does
we would love you to consider joining
the knowledge Network my email will be
available at the end of this
presentation I would love to hear from
you if you are interested as a physician
or as an institution in participating in
virtual trials in order to be able to
maximize learning and this includes
investigator-initiated trials for those
of you who would like to be able to very
quickly have us help you find you know
people who are interested in your
questions that can pull together studies
much more quickly than you could on your
own please let me hear from you if you
have services that might be helpful to
patients in the spirit that we talked
about in terms of helping understand the
cancer or plan the treatment or be able
to validate the treatment clinically we
want to integrate your tests into the
system and provide you with real-time
feedback on how well it's working to
inform treatment so you using a lot to
be gotten by being part of this let me
hear from you as well if you're if you
have data that you're willing to share
into a data Commons this is not my
primary focus there's lots of other
people who are trying to build data Khan
it's very hard to get people to share
data I don't quite understand why people
seem much more willing to share the
knowledge at the level of tumor boards
which i think is much more valuable than
the raw data per se but for whatever
reason I'm going to make a suggestion
and I would like to hear from you if you
have comments on this which is that all
of the databases that all of the data
that people are compiling but they want
to sell for quote big bucks to Pharma or
to payers it to Wall Street or to
whoever very little of that data is
being used for clinical purposes and we
could set up a federated you know
database if you like will you hold on to
your data you're not really sharing it
you're not destroying your business
model of aggregating it let's say and
sharing it and selling it to whoever you
want to sell it to but use your data as
part of a system where we can go out to
everyone who has data and say baby ask
some standardized queries that are
clinically relevant such as based on
your data how when you treat my patient
a B or C right that's the type of
question you can answer it won't disturb
your business model and if you would
like to be part of that network we know
some technology that exists for being
able to do that and do it in a way that
in fact will increase your your odds of
selling your data to someone because the
federated queries are just the flipside
of aggregating your data pooling it to
be able to generate something that's
much more valuable that could be sold
and if you would like to be part of that
kind of network let me know and finally
as I said earlier if building you know
infrastructure is your thing we could
certainly use certainly use help on that
front as well so I will close then with
a couple of takeaways first of all as I
said if we're honest all of oncology
advanced oncology as an experiment and
one that's today unplanned uncoordinated
unobserved we might as well do all those
things and not just learn something but
maximize the learning so we don't get
into situations who are running two
thousand checkpoint trials which is just
confusing for the patient and very
very inefficient for the system as a
whole no one knows the optimal optimal
way to use the thousands of treatments
that we already have not all of them are
approved for cancer some of them are
used off-label but they have to get used
enough in cocktails and regimens in ways
that are there's just exponentially more
interesting things to try than there are
people so we have to be very thoughtful
about the way we run these sequential
experiments and AI was just made for
that third cancer is primarily not a big
data problem at least the way I'm
defining it the goal is to use the AI to
figure out what data you need and how
efficiently how to get it most
efficiently experiment planning again
the best source of guidance at this
point in time their current state of
knowledge is to go ask me experts and
see what they're thinking but to do that
in a way that drives consensus and then
tries to coordinate across the experts
in order to be able to drive things more
efficiently and cancer doesn't need a
moonshot well maybe it does but the
point is that what I'm talking about
is completely basically green space
everyone's trying to invent the next
drug and no one is trying to think about
how to optimize the drugs that we
already have which is a big you know a
blind spot so closing so in the end I
ask the question you know can I beat
cancer and certainly can't cure cancer
but can it help individuals beat cancer
and my answer there is not yet maybe not
ever but we can certainly save hundreds
of thousands of lives starting
immediately because we're not trying
necessarily to even invent new knowledge
or new drugs
we're just trying to put together things
we have in a much more efficient system
that can drive individual outcomes and
maximize collective learning secondly AI
will transform everyday oncology into a
virtual trial that's continuously
learning from all patients and that's
very very important simply because the
number of patients are far fewer than
the number of things you might want to
test so you have to be very efficient
and
is the way to do that and finally a I
can't do anything by itself it needs to
be tied into the cancer world and it's
I'm trying to do my best but I need your
help
and I urge you to join forces so thank
you very much and I'm eager to hear your
questions Thank You dr. Tannenbaum
before that invitation we will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button once there's many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is what
are the implications of the recently
passed right to try legislation on what
your initiative so I think what the
questioner is thinking about is that in
order to be able to run the experiments
that we want to want to run the key is
being able to get access to the drugs
and that is very very difficult often
there certainly you know ways that the
FDA has opened up pathways like
compassionate use expanded access and
people and the FDA is very proud of the
fact that they approve 99% of the
applications that come to them but the
pharma companies and the biotechs that
make these drugs are reluctant to
release drugs through these pathways for
various reasons they don't they don't
want to screw up their their pivotal
trials which will lead to registration
with some side effect on an uncontrolled
population but also you know the FDA I
kind of very explicitly or implicitly
and the companies are scared of how you
know there is the results of these
off-label experiments are out of out of
protocol experiments are going to get
used this tremendous interest however on
the part of patients and cancer Commons
through our ask service
every day I get you know requests from
patients not just for advice on what to
do but how to get access to the drugs
and the patients are struggling here and
I think that you know if there's any
thing that right to try is going to do
it's going to create tremendous interest
and on the part of patients who are out
of options in trying experimental
options I believe these companies are
going to get overrun with requests and I
think that you know right to try in some
ways is fundamentally no different than
expanded access because it doesn't
require the companies to make the drug
available if they want to they can but I
think that if we can do right to try in
a responsible way and by that I mean
capturing the treatment decisions the
rationales and the data that results in
this kind of real-world evidence setting
that we can actually use right to try to
move the field much more forward by
coordinating all these right to try
experiments and the challenge from right
to try is that the legislation really
requires almost no reporting other than
adverse events and so we need to we need
to think about how we can exploit you
know what the situation is that Congress
has handed us in order to be able to
drive learning and I think right to try
is potentially a tectonic event that
will really assure in the golden age of
the types of things I'm talking about
which is using drugs in interesting new
ways for the immediate benefit of
patients doctors Tanenbaum how does your
AI powered virtual trial platform
compare with master protocol Bayesian
adaptive trials such as iSpy GBM agile
and precision promise that's that's an
excellent question
the in these are these adaptive Bayesian
trials are really a major step forward
in terms of ugh and and many of these
cases they have an arbitrary number of
harms and they're trying to optimize the
use of the allocation of a patient
population who those are
in ways that will really drive approval
of many new drugs and of course that's a
good thing on the other hand I think
until we can crack the problem of
optimizing the drugs that we already
have that we're not going to make a
major dent in cancer in some sense the
2004 scan sur dog is not going to move
the needle more than you know one over
2001 simply because these drugs will
almost always be used in a combination
with other drugs at the cutting edge of
therapy so what I'm talking about really
could be viewed as deeply complementary
to these Bayesian platform trials think
about it this way the platform trials
are well but let's say deeply
complementary and extending these
platforms to all patients on all
treatments all the time so the platform
trials are trials right they're open
it's particular sites they are have
inclusion and exclusion criteria which
may be looser than in the past because
there are lots of arms to steer patients
toward but nonetheless there will be a
drop out one can expect the forty or 15%
and between those two constraints the
patient not living near the site and
being inclusion/exclusion the number of
patients that these platform trials are
going to reach is going to be limited
and the amount of agility in those
platform trials there's still most of
them are single arm a single drug per
arm at trials so what we're doing is
complimentary in two ways one is we can
take all the patients that they are not
able to interval either because the
patients don't live near them and can't
go into them in the first place or the
patients drop out of the trial for
whatever reason they're in an arm and
they fell and they drop out to be able
to take those patients and do some
interesting experiments and the other
complimentary way is to be able to we
can run small you know pop-up studies of
interesting new drugs and almost as a
sandbox to qualify drugs for later
adoption as an arm within one of the
platform trials and conversely when
a drug graduates and in the sense of a
successful testing from one of these
platform trials we can then start
experimenting with that drug in rational
combinations in a very efficient way so
you know I would say that you know in
the simplistic
way I like to think about these adaptive
platform trials as an arm in our virtual
trial and conversely our virtual trial
as an arm in the platform trials they're
very complimentary in that way and if
any of you are involved in one of the
platform trials you have my email I want
to hear from you
how can Big Data initiatives such as
Flatiron cancer link and project data
sphere contribute okay so I've talked
about data various times in my
conversation and sometimes a little bit
disparagingly to say you know well there
is no data on me interesting things that
haven't been tried yet but I want to be
clear we had access to data it would be
very helpful
certainly for generating hypotheses on
the one hand for being able to do
validation retrospectively before we try
things prospectively good for that so if
if we can in fact get data that would be
very very good having clinical grade
real-world evidence is absolutely
essential to the kind of virtual trials
that we're talking about and these
typically aren't you know these
databases are not used for clinical
decision-making they're used they're
collected and then sold off to pharma
for target discovery or marketing
figuring out who's using what drugs I
think there's an opportunity to be able
to tie all these projects together in a
way that actually will make them useful
to clinicians and in a way that doesn't
disturb the business models of people
who want to you know monetize their data
so if you have data and you would like
to be part of this we are working with
some of the organizations to thank all
the organizations that were in your
question and in particular to you know
project data sphere cancer link Flatiron
pulling these together in a way that's
good for patients
and actually in the end might even
promote increase the value of your data
through some commit of commercial
pooling optional to be discussed please
get in touch with me if you have those
kinds of opportunities to is there
another question yes it looks like we
have time for one more
my company develops technology for early
detection of cancer how can we get
involved and what are the benefits so
this is again maybe speaking to the
slide of saying you know here's this
ecosystem I have a company I didn't talk
about early detection it's certainly a
very very important thing it's the focus
of you know some major companies like
Braille and garden and I'm going to
answer this question in a slightly
generalized way which is whatever you're
doing that relates to cancer in some way
I want you to think about how it might
be helpful to the process that I'm
talking about in terms of using this
these services as knowledge or
constraints to guide the search and if
you're talking about for example early
detection it's likely that the
technology and markers that you're
working with for early detection can
also be used for real-time monitoring of
response to therapy and if you think
about you know AI driving a search over
possibilities if you can get an early
response at an early indication of
whether a particular branch of the
search is working and if not you can
switch to a different branch in order to
be able to get more shots on goal that's
hugely valuable to the overall
efficiency of the search so here's a
case where you take something which is
nominally not relevant to what I'm
talking about namely
early detection and turn it into
something that is directly relevant
which is real-time monitoring and so as
a challenge to all of you you know if
you're working on things and whether or
not it's AI or not is irrelevant at this
point because we're gonna use the AI to
integrate your stuff in an efficient way
if you have something that could be
helpful in terms of understanding what's
going on in this patient and what to do
about it and how to monitor whether
you're making progress or be able to
increase the odds and it's go
to work preclinically before you give it
to the patient we need you to be part of
the Seco system please please get in
touch before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from laberd's letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye